بعد 15 شهرا على بدء حرب روسيا على
اوكرانيا وقبل حوالي شهر من قمه قادته في
ظل يس عاصمه ليتوانيا يعزز حلف شمال
الاطلسي دفاعاته ويعدل خططه لحمايه جميع
اعضاء فكيف يبدو المشهد في استونيا
الخاصره الشرقيه للحلف تجري دول الناتو
تدريبات تتضمن شن هجوم محمول جوا لقوات
امريكيه وعمليه انزال ليليه لعناصر من
مشاه البحريه البريطانيه وانزال وحدات
كوماندوس من المظليين الفرنسيين التدريبات
التي اطلق عليها اسم العاصفه الربيعيه
تاتي في اطار استراتيجيات دفاعيه جديده
للحلف هدفها تعزيز الانتشار بسرعه كبيره
في مهله قصيره جدا لجيوش الدول الواقعه
على خط الجبهه وتشكل نقطه دفاع متقدمه
حلف شمال الاطلسي رد حرب روسيا على
اوكرانيا بنشر اربع مجموعات تكتيكيه جديده
في سلوفاكيا والمجر ورومانيا وبلغاريا
اضافه الى اربع مجموعات شكلها في بولندا
ودول البلطيق وتعتزم دول الحلف الان تعزيز
عدد قوتها المنتشره في دول البطيخ الثلاث
لاتفيا واستونيا
بالاضافه الى بولندا لتصبح بحجم لواء ما
يعني حشد الاف الجنود الاضافيين حيث ومتى
تدعو الضروره يفترض ان يصدق قاده الحلف في
فيلينيوس على خطط اكثر تفصيلا توضح كيفيه
الدفاع عن كل منطقه في حال تعرضها لهجوم
مع ذكر عدد القوات والدول الاصل ومواقع
الانتشار
استعدادات النت لا تتوقف على تدريبات
العاصفه الربيعيه ولا على عمليات الانتشار
الجديده التي ستتطلب حتما مبالغ ماليه
وموارد وقوات بل ثمت خطوه شهدتها الساعه
الماضيه وصفت باستعراض قوه لحلف شمال
الاطلسي فقد وصلت حامله الطائرات
الامريكيه جيرل فورد وهي اكبر سفينه حربيه
في العالم الى اوسلو وقد اقيمت منطقه حظر
جوي وبحري كبير حول هذه السفينه
هي النسخه الاولى من الجيل الجديد لحاملات
الطائرات وتعمل بالدفع النووي ويمكن
لحامله الطائرات هذه البالغ طولها 335
مترا استيعاب 90 طائره يفترض ان تتوجه
حامله الطائرات الى الدائره القطبيه
الشماليه مع بدء مناورات جويه تجمع حوالي